buonasera a tutti ringrazio la
professoressa asciutto è il politecnico
di milano per l'invito a questo ted
io in realtà comincerò e concluderò in
questa conversazione con voi mostrandovi
un'unica immagine
un'immagine che in realtà è una
citazione è una citazione di una
copertina dell'economist di qualche anno
fa del 2012 che si intitolava the third
industrial revolution poi noi siamo
abituati a chiamarlo anche quarta
rivoluzione industriale
diciamo questo tema del 3 e del 4 è
rimasto un po un mistero però stiamo
parlando dei cambiamenti tecnologici e
quindi dell'introduzione delle
tecnologie digitali
nell'ambito della nostra vita e anche
della produzione che cosa c'entra questa
immagine che appunto mostra un nuovo
lavoratore che attraverso un computer
produce degli oggetti con una citazione
di una fabbrica diciamo una delle
fabbriche che eravamo abituati a
conoscere ai confini delle nostre città
ecco che cosa c'entra questa rivoluzione
con il tema dei confini delle periferie
con il limite
ovviamente per me il tema è declinato
sulle città per l'intervento che farò la
questione delle periferie dei confini
narra di periferie e confini delle aree
urbane delle città cosa c'entra questa
immagine
noi siamo stati abituati e lo diceva
prima il professor pasqui a immaginare
le città chiuse o racchiuse questo
almeno fino agli anni ottanta dello
scorso secolo
ovviamente chiuse dalle aree produttive
diciamo cosa circondava e cosa segnava
il confine della città di milano per
esempio verso sesto o anche verso sud lo
segnavano le fabbriche e gli
gli stabilimenti produttivi e i
quartieri dove gli operai che lavoravano
in quelle fabbriche andavano a vivere o
si ritiravano a sera diciamo dopo la
giornata lavorativa è successo qualcosa
qualcosa di importante che ha cambiato
anche la configurazione delle aree
urbane nei nostri centri delle nazioni
di industrializzazione matura a partire
dagli anni settanta e ancor più negli
anni 80
queste fabbriche hanno cominciato a
chiudere diciamo l'idea che le nostre
città ospitassero la produzione la
produzione pesante diciamo anche
produzione di acciaio produzione chimica
non è stata più coerente con i
cambiamenti del modo di produrre del
modo di vivere la fine la crisi di
quello che gli economisti e sociologi
hanno chiamato fordismo diciamo il modo
di produrre dentro grandi stabilimenti
produttivi spesso ai limiti delle aree
urbane ha cominciato ad entrare in crisi
a trasformarsi da quel momento in poi
noi siamo stati abituati ad immaginare
che le città non fossero più il luogo
della produzione delle cose degli
oggetti ma fossero destinate
esclusivamente o quasi esclusivamente ad
ospitare i servizi l'immateriale
l'economia urbana ha cominciato a
declinarsi sempre di più come un
economia dei servizi la stessa città di
milano
dagli anni 80 in poi è stata pensata
persino dagli stessi cittadini milanesi
come la città della finanza diciamo
della moda dell'economia immateriale
questo perché la produzione che co pure
serve alla all'economia mondiale diciamo
nel suo complesso ha cominciato a
migrare altrove per una serie di ragioni
diciamo che non sono poi l'oggetto di
questa discussione
i cambiamenti di cui l'economist parla
con questa copertina che ci dicono di
un'applicazione possibile delle
tecnologie del digitale non soltanto
nell'ambito dell'informatica
dell'immateriale ma addirittura
nell'ambito della produzione delle cose
qualcuno più autorevole di me in questo
campo ha parlato di un passaggio dal
beat all'atomo cioè la possibilità
programmando attraverso gli strumenti
del digitale di utilizzare macchinari
che producono oggetti la stampa 3d viene
spesso citata diciamo come esempio di
questo modo di utilizzare digitale per
avere un prodotto che anche un prodotto
materiale non più soltanto in materiale
queste trasformazioni tecnologiche
consentono oggi di produrre anche
oggetti materiali oggetti utili diciamo
alla vita quotidiana in spazi di
dimensioni ridotte con un basso livello
di emissioni quindi diciamo con una
compatibilità ambientale possibile
rispetto alle aree urbane alla alle aree
dove si vive e ci indicano una
trasformazione possibile delle città che
possono tornare ad essere aree di
produzione anche materiale nella
presentazione che mi ha preceduto veniva
mostrata una bella fotografia del poli
factory uno spazio del politecnico di
milano dedicato alla manifattura
digitale o la manifattura additiva dove
studenti makers ricercatori sperimentano
soluzioni produttive applicate ai campi
più vari diciamo dalla bio medicale all
kerr al all'aerospazio a quanto diciamo
è possibile immaginare attraverso la
programmazione
digitale applicata alla alla manifattura
quel laboratorio diciamo aveva
all'aspetto di essere uno spazio
compatibile con la vita con l'area
urbana persino con con l'abitato
circostante la città di milano negli
ultimi anni si è dimostrata essere molto
viva e molto capace di produrre
iniziativa spontanea sul tema delle
nuove produzioni manifatturiere che
utilizzano il digitale noi abbiamo
censito come amministrazione supportati
anche dagli istituti di ricerca delle
università che nella città di milano si
è concentrato spontaneamente è il più
alto numero di fab lab maker space in
confronto con altre città paragonabili a
noi in termini di sviluppo economico di
numero della della popolazione siamo
avanti da da questo punto di vista
perché questo aspetto può essere come
dire una risposta in positivo al tema e
al bisogno che anche le amministrazioni
pubbliche hanno di ripensare e
rigenerare le periferie in primis perché
noi abbiamo visto che laddove si insedia
una nuova attività produttiva anche di
nuova generazione o forse soprattutto di
nuova generazione in quell'area in quel
territorio si genera un piccolo
ecosistema di animazione territoriale
animazione economica che spesso intorno
al nuovo insediamento produce anche
attività di commercio attività sociale
lo abbiamo visto negli anni passati
quando è esploso nella nostra città e
soprattutto ai confini di nord ovest
questa perché a nord ovest poi ce lo
spiegheranno gli urbanisti sociologi
esploso il fenomeno dei core king cioè
molti spazi che erano in disuso perché
erano ex stabilimenti industriali o aree
abbandonate magari messe a mercato anche
a costi
hanno cominciato ad ospitare nuove
configurazioni produttive nuovi luoghi
di lavoro che non erano più il
concentrato gli operai nella grande
fabbrica che vediamo nell'immagine ma
spazi multifunzionali dove lavoratori
diversi si ritrovano non solo per
condividere lo spazio fisico di lavoro
ed evidentemente abbattere i costi ma
anche per condividere delle relazioni di
mercato diciamo utili quel fenomeno di
rigenerazione
intorno a questi nuovi spazi del lavoro
ha prodotto non soltanto la
riqualificazione dello spazio in sé ma
piccoli ecosistemi in cui diciamo lo
scambio di mercato e lo scambio sociale
sono andati insieme generando poi un po
più sicurezza
magari piccolo commercio che si è
organizzato in intorno ai quei luoghi
ovunque un nuovo nucleo diciamo di
produzione che abbia delle
caratteristiche di creazione di
relazioni e anche diciamo un impatto
ambientale sostenibile e di aiuto alla
al processo e al percorso di
rigenerazione urbana c'è stato un
momento in cui queste attività di
rigenerazione sono avvenute tipicamente
attraverso l'insediamento dei grandi
centri commerciali c'è stato tutta una
fase sul finire del secolo scorso in cui
sembrava che anche le amministrazioni
pubbliche fossero condannati ad
immaginare la rigenerazione urbana
soltanto con grandi mall centri
commerciali in realtà oggi anche quel
modello sta entrando in crisi
noi abbiamo scommesso di fianco
all'insediamento produttivo di nuove
produzioni appunto nel nelle aree
periferiche utilizzando anche agli spazi
pubblici
diciamo dismessi in disuso alcuni esempi
sono stati citati altri se ne possono
fare uno tra tutti è lo spazio base in
via tortona la rigenerazione di una
grande ex fabbrica diciamo l'ansaldo che
produceva acciaio oggi produce idee
e culture a fianco a questi processi
anche il commercio ha visto delle
profonde trasformazioni
oggi diciamo l'idea che l'attività
commerciale si svolga nei grandi centri
commerciali nei mol è un po in declino
persino nella patria d'origine di questo
modello gli stati uniti d'america
oggi il modello dell'ibridazione di
attività commerciali attività sociali
sembra essere un modello emergente e
vincente anche dal punto di vista del
sostegno alle amministrazioni nel
costruire appunto socialità raccordo
sviluppo del commercio
questo lo stiamo facendo con un'idea di
rigenerazione dei mercati comunali
coperti anche questi spesso in aree
periferiche servivano i quartieri operai
diciamo i quartieri dei lavoratori negli
anni 50 con l'obiettivo di calmierare i
prezzi
oggi con un intervento pubblico che si
affianca a l'intervento privato quei
luoghi diventano luoghi libri di in cui
si affianca l'attività di vendita anche
l'attività sociale di aggregazione e di
somministrazione e sempre più spesso
dove si compra il cibo lo si consuma e
non sono luoghi divisi un caso per tutti
e mercato del lorenteggio in un
quartiere periferico che con la
commistione tra l'attività dei
commercianti tradizionali e associazioni
culturali ha dato nuova vita ad uno
spazio che non è solo uno spazio
commerciale ma è uno spazio di
aggregazione
dico questo perché io credo che tutti
diciamo questo progetto di rigenerazione
delle periferie attraverso la produzione
e il commercio quindi attività
economiche a fianco a quelle tipiche di
chi si occupa dell'abitare cioè i luoghi
se anche in periferia dove le persone
possono vivere risponde probabilmente a
due grandi domande la prima è quella di
ripensare diciamo le periferie come
spazi vitali come spazi che rendano
coerente l'attività del lavorare con
l'attività del vivere
e il secondo è diciamo un tema che non
ha a che fare solo con le città che fare
un po con tutti i nostri paesi
sviluppati
cioè l'idea di poter offrire una
risposta in termini di opportunità
occupazionale ad un gran numero di
persone soprattutto alle generazioni più
giovani che sono state abituate a
pensare che la propria condizione di
vita e di lavoro è destinata ad essere
un po peggiore di quella dei propri
padri
noi siamo in una fase economica e
sociale in italia ma non solo in italia
in cui compito della politica è dentro
la politica con la p maiuscola io vedo
anche l'azione dell'amministratore
locale deve immaginare diciamo soluzioni
opportunità per quella che noi abbiamo
chiamato una classe media diciamo
persone che non necessariamente sono dei
talenti assoluti o degli innovatori
assoluti che sono però portatori di
nuove competenze le competenze digitali
sono queste che devono trovare un
proprio ruolo nel mondo e nella società
diciamo attraverso un lavoro di qualità
accessibile in grado di poter dare
soddisfazioni a se stessi diciamo e alle
proprie famiglie soddisfazione non
soltanto economica
il tema delle nuove produzioni di come
cambia la tradizione produttiva italiana
che tipicamente una tradizione fatta di
manifattura diciamo noi abbiamo un
expertise e su questo e come questo
cambiamento possa incrociare il bisogno
di dare risposte a persone che cercano
possibilità diciamo di lavoro che sono
magari mediamente più scolarizzati dei
propri genitori con competenze digitali
maggiori con competenze linguistiche
maggiori e che non trovano soddisfazione
nel mercato è un tema
e se questo tema può a trovare risposta
attraverso un utilizzo non escludente ma
includente diciamo della nuova
tecnologia anche in ambito produttivo e
persino in ambito commerciale
è una grande scommessa su cui noi stiamo
investendo e che consente o può
consentire se il mix tra politiche
pubbliche e politiche anche degli attori
privati funzioni di dare diciamo nuova
vita e nuova coesione alle periferie
delle aree urbane cioè la manifattura
l'industria il lavoro che torna in città
può essere non solo un tema economico ma
un tema di qualità del vivere su cui
forse vale la pena diciamo scommettere
in termini di progettazione non solo da
parte del pubblico ma anche da parte
delle università e di altri operatori
grazie
[Applauso]